the education secretary Mel
Cardona has just stepped in it by
quoting a Republican president but
getting the quote just a little bit
wrong you know we're going to set up
follow-up calls with every Governor we
met with to make sure we're available um
as uh I think it was President Reagan
said we're from the government we're
here to help um there's there are
resources there there's technical
assistance there and there's a Playbook
that could support the work you're doing
count on us as a partner in this our
students are waiting thank
you was that the quote did Ronald Reagan
say we're from the government and we're
here to help or did Ronald Reagan say
it's probably one of the most famous
Reagan quotes did Reagan say the nine
most frightening words in the English
language are I'm from the government and
I'm here to help I think it was the
latter the meaning of which is obviously
the opposite of what the education
secretary said and a politician getting
a quote wrong even perfectly totally
wrong a politician not knowing anything
is scandalous enough but it's
especially scandalous and ironic when it
is the head of the Department of
Education that tells you everything you
need to know about the state of American
Education by the way this guy wasn't
just some random no- nothing congressman
who got elevated by Biden as a political
favor which sometimes happens this guy
was previously the commissioner of the
Connecticut Department of Education
before that he was a an elementary
school principal he's been in education
his whole life he's got four degrees
he's got a Bachelor's a BS an MS an syc
which is apparently some education
specialist degree and a doctor of
Education in
Edd and he he exhibits a stunning
ignorance and I don't I don't want to
attack him too much it's probably not
his fault he got all these silly degrees
the degrees don't don't mean anything
anymore he went to a bunch of schools
the schools don't really mean anything
anymore and he's running a department
that hasn't hasn't done anything
productive basically ever and now people
are making fun of him because he doesn't
know anything about anything the Reagan
quote was the opposite of what he said
but Reagan was also somewhat wrong in
his quote right now text nolles to 98
9898 diversify your savings with
precious medals while stockpiling silver
in your home safe with B gold groups
special of the year now through December
22nd for every $5,000 you spend with
Birch gold they will send you a 1o
silver eagle coin for free text NOS can
Wes to 998 9898 to claim your
eligibility now you can purchase gold
and silver and have it shipped directly
to your home or have Birch Gold's
precious metal Specialists help you
convert an existing Ira of 401k into a
tax sheltered Ira in gold for no money
out of pocket keep it for yourself or
give something with real value as a
stocking stuffer this year just text the
keyword nolles canw to 9898 98 to claim
your eligibility with an A+ rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold text noes canas
to 998 9898 claim your eligibility for
free silver un qualifying purchases
before December 22nd that's nolles kws
to 98 98 98 stock up now baby right now
go to EK pure.com use code N35
envirocleanse just announced a massive
Black Friday discount it has extended
their sale this week the best way to
fight a cold or flu is to not get it in
the first place that is why we got
enviral cleanse for the office the new
science of air purification with their
limited time extended Black Friday sale
you will save 35% and viroc cleanse is
an inhome air purifying unit proven to
capture and Destroy flu viruses bacteria
toxins mold and allergens from your home
see by the way I went on the road for
Thanksgiving and what happens I had been
sounding just just fine I go on the road
I come back I've got the little sniffles
it's not I should have taken enviral
cleanse on the road enviral cleanse
technology is so powerful it was chosen
to purify the air systems on board Navy
ships and Subs enviral cleans helps keep
our service men and women healthier it
can keep you and your family healthier
too enviral cleans is the only home air
purifier that promises Better Health by
keeping your home free of Cold and Flu
viruses right now it Sav 35% during
their extended Black Friday sale plus
get fast free shipping EK pure.com code
nolles 35 35% off EK .c code N35 for 35%
off EK pure.com I love
Reagan I visited the
ranch I have read the Reagan books I
quote Ronald Reagan regularly I have a
Ronald Reagan belt buckle I love the guy
okay please don't I have strong Gipper
bonafides but the man did get a few
things wrong okay and in his defense he
lived at a different time he was
fighting a different enemy he was a cold
warrior now we live in a different time
and we need to recognize that we can't
just dig up the corpse of Ronald Reagan
try to reanimate him like a zombie and
have him solve all of our problems and
and one thing one little bit of Ronald
Reagan wisdom that if it was sufficient
in the 80s is no longer sufficient is
this quote that the Biden education
secretary was trying to repeat
unsuccessfully the nine most frightening
words in the English language are I'm
from the government and I'm here to
help not
necessarily government is not always
bad government exists for a reason
government exists it's a a natural
institution it a man is the political
creature we're a social animal it exists
to enforce Justice and to uh facilitate
our all living together and uh the
purpose of government is not merely to
just totally leave us alone that would
be called Anarchy that would be the
negation of government the purpose of of
government is uh to do good and avoid
evil it's just like our own individual
purposes and government can overstep
this is why we have another principle
called subsidiarity which is the notion
that decisions ought to be made at the
most familiar and local level possible
where they can be efficiently and
properly made and done but there is a
role for government
okay and the fact that conservatives
have treated this funny little Reagan
quip as you know the the gospel truth as
as the 11th commandment or something is
one of the reasons why we've lost
because we've seeded the political power
to the left and then the libs wield that
political power and we stand on the side
and we Snicker and we say you Libs you
unprincipled tyranical Libs you you
think the government's going to solve
your problems yeah the government's
solving their problems we're their
problem the conservatives are the
Liberals problem and the their use of
the government is solving their problem
by kicking us out of the Public Square
and harassing us and surveiling us and
taking away our rights and showing up at
our homes and arresting us for
nonsense yeah the solution to that
problem is to wield government properly
with
Justice and not just seed the whole
Public Square to the libs man that was a
great clip huh now hey ring the bell sub
subscribe to the Michael YouTube channel
we'll see you next time